la première des choses c'est que j'ai
fait ces déclarations en étant plus en
fonction à la présidence la république
non je représente et moi même tout à
fait et je veux donner mon opinion
personnelle
il n'y a pas une opposition officielle
du ministère de l'intérieur à un projet
de réforme de la sécurité
il ya eu un problème on va dire de
communication avec un certain nombre de
personnes deux pour être exact haut
fonctionnaire au port occupant des
fonctions importantes aux miss à
l'intérieur et qui étaient opposés pour
des raisons corporatiste je pense que ce
problème a été réglé depuis il
n'engageait pas le ministère de
l'intérieur ni ministre de l'intérieur
il engageait deux personnes qui ont des
fonctions éminentes et qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas voir ce projet se faire
pour des raisons corporatistes et pour
des raisons de protection de leur
périmètre
je le dis qu avec un avis personnel ça
n'engage que moi ce que je dis mais ça a
été réglé par la suite et je n'étais pas
l'interlocuteur du ministère de
l'intérieur à la présidence concernant
ce projet de réforme
le seul interlocuteur le seul chef le
seul qui avait la légitimité pour parler
du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est patrick strzoda c'est le seul
départ celui l'interface avec maintes
alors nous avons travaillé en interne
sur un projet est dès lors que le projet
a commencé à s'ébruiter un peu il ya une
opposition nette de 2 personnes qui
défendent et leur pré carré
jusqu'à ce que j'ai pu voir à ses
habituels dans l'administration